as controversy proved over Zanu three
trillion dollar stimulus package passed
by the House of Representatives last
week many people have pointed out that
other countries have been much more
generous with their stimulus checks as
well as unemployment benefits so the US
should not think twice and giving out
more stimulus checks is this actually
true and if so which country actually
gave out the most stimulus checks
[Music]
first of all this video is going to
focus on specifically how much stimulus
that government gave to unemployed
citizens in the form of stimulus checks
and extra unemployment benefits over a
period of four months this will not look
at the amount given to businesses or
bailouts and so on so starting off let's
look at the good old United States so
far they have given out a one-time
payment of $1,200 on top of this an
unemployed individual can expect an
extra $600 per week up to four months
this amount is at how much they would
normally receive from state unemployment
insurance and other programs thus the
average u.s. citizen could expect ten
thousand eight hundred dollars over four
months if they are unemployed plus
another five hundos per child as a
one-time payment moving on let's take a
look at Canada as many people point out
that Canada gives out more Canada is
giving out $2,000 per month for four
months at first glance which seem like
Canada is giving out more money as their
stimulus amount is $8,000 as opposed to
America's 1200 however we have to also
consider that Canada has no extra
unemployment benefits furthermore
something else that is misleading is
that the Canadian dollar uses the same
symbol as the American dollar
but they're not actually the same 8,000
Canadian dollars is equivalent to five
thousand seven hundred and fifty US
dollars so Canada's total amount is not
as much as it first appears or at least
according to Forbes next up let's look
at some European countries who are
giving out crazy amounts of cash as for
Britain Britain is giving a staggering
80% of unemployed workers salaries up to
2500 pounds a month considering that the
median income in the UK is 30 1617
dollars
this means that the average unemployed
Brit would get two thousand four hundred
and sixteen dollars a month this adds up
to nine thousand six hundred and
sixty-four dollars over four months
France on the other hand is offering 70%
of unemployed workers salaries and they
have a really generous limit at six
thousand nine hundred and twenty seven
euros
month or 7575 dollars
I'm not sure if people earning that much
money really need help but anyways the
average French resident makes thirty one
thousand one hundred twelve dollars a
year so the average unemployed French
citizen would receive one thousand eight
hundred and fifteen dollars per month
this comes out to a solid seven thousand
two hundred and sixty over four months
Germany has a very similar plan that
offers 67% of an individual salary and
again has just as generous of a maximum
at sixty seven hundred euros per month
with an average income of 33333 dollars
the average German would receive one
thousand eight hundred and sixty one
dollars or seven thousand four hundred
and forty four dollars over four months
Spain is paying up to seventy percent of
workers salaries but they have a much
more reasonable maximum at 1412 euros a
month with the meeting income of twenty
one thousand nine hundred and fifty nine
dollars that average Spaniard received
one thousand two hundred eighty one
dollars a month or five thousand one
hundred twenty four dollars over four
months Italy like the UK has pledged to
give up to 80 percent of employee salary
with a maximum 1130 euros per month
unfortunately however this is only for
nine weeks or about two months but we'll
assume that they do this for four months
in order to get a better comparison of
the rate of similars checks from the
various countries with a median income
of twenty thousand eighty-five dollars
the average Italian can expect the
maximum of one thousand 130 euros or
twelve forty one dollars if this was
given out over four months this would
come out of four thousand nine hundred
and sixty four dollars
our last two European countries the
Netherlands and Denmark are taking a
completely different approach instead of
paying stimulus checks to unemployed
citizens they're paying these checks to
businesses to prevent people from
getting laid off in the first place
businesses are only eligible for these
funds if they don't lay off any of their
employees the Netherlands is offering
90% and Denmark is offering seventy five
to ninety percent depending on the
business personally I think this is the
most effective method discussed so far
as employees get their money
don't lose your job while businesses
aren't footing two months of the bill
and given that the Netherlands and
Denmark have some of the highest incomes
in the world this comes out to a nice
eleven thousand 575 with Netherlands and
12194 Denmark over four months as for
Asia South Korea is offering 70% or more
of workers wages plus a possible cash
payment for certain industries the
average South Korean can expect nine
thousand five hundred thirty four
dollars over four months plus sometimes
a bit more Hong Kong though not
technically a country is offering fifty
percent of workers salaries for six
months which comes out to about one
thousand one hundred and sixty dollars a
month or four thousand six hundred forty
for four months
Japan is offering a single payment of
nine hundred thirty dollars to every
single Japanese citizen despite their
situation India is not really offering
any cash payments directly however they
are giving out free food on a regular
basis to eight hundred million people as
well as five million rupees or about
sixty six thousand dollars in health
insurance for frontline workers and
finally Australia is giving out seven
hundred and fifty dollars in cash
payments to low-income earners along
with about one thousand dollars every
two weeks for furloughed employees which
comes out to about eight thousand
dollars for the average furloughed
employee taking a step back and looking
at all of their countries it seems like
the Scandinavian country of Denmark has
once again come out on top but this is
well not too accurate of course there
are some programs and nuances that were
probably missed in these estimates but
more importantly we have to remember
that the cost of living and health care
is vastly different among these
countries basically every country on
this list other than the US has
universal health care so though many of
these countries are giving out less
money the income received in these
countries is more useful than in the US
but this video wasn't made to knock down
one system or praise another but rather
showed that all of these countries are
giving out thousands of dollars or at
least trying to sure some systems may
give up more and/or be more effect
but for the most part all of these
countries are crying their best to help
their citizens through this rough time
so instead of getting hung up on the
differences we should be grateful as
many countries aren't giving out any
money but that's just what I think major
drop a like if you agree if I missed a
major country then make sure to comment
that down below and if you like some
more questions logically answered then
consider subscribing but until then I'm
hari I'll see you guys on the next one